Roughly 9% of the rubbish we collect could
be recycled instead.
Let’s take a closer look at how we use the
recycling bin.
Everything you put into the bin, should be
clean and loose, not in a bag.
Lids and tops from bottles and jars should
be removed.
If they’re plastic, they should go in the rubbish
but any scrap metal can be recycled at Southbrook Resource Recovery Park.
Other items that can’t be accepted include
broken glass, milk or juice cartons
also known as Tetrapak, polystyrene and soft plastics.
Soft plastics include anything that you can easily scrunch up in your hand,
this includes bubble wrap, food wrap, chip packets and plastic bags.
Nappies should go into your rubbish and food soiled
cardboard like pizza boxes,
or napkins should go into your organics bin for composting.
So what should go into recycling?
Glass bottles and jars.
Bottles and containers made from plastic
types one through to seven.
Tins, cans and aerosols.
And loose, clean, flat cardboard and paper.
To learn more or to sign up for collection
reminders visit waimakariri.govt.nz/rethinkrubbish